us now and I'm delighted he's with us
North Dakota Senator Kevin Kramer joins
me now I think the first time on the
angle Senator thank you for joining us
um some breaking news uh that just came
in on the border deal which kind of
plays right into what I was saying about
how there'll be new tweaks and a bit
okay so this provision just released by
an unknown Senate Source if Crossings
exceed
8500 in a single day DHS would be
required to close the border migrants
illegally crossing the border now under
the proposal any migrant who tries to
cross the border twice um while it is
closed would be banned from entering the
US for one year first question Senator
don't they already have the power to
close the border to migrants illegally
crossing the border isn't that the whole
point of our immigration
laws well the problem Lauren thank you
for the opportunity to be honest it's my
pleasure um right now they have the
discretion to do that what near as I can
tell from the language was you just
showed me which is the first time I've
seen it they're required it says that
DHS secretary would be required at 8,500
now granted 8500 is way too high a
number but there were several days last
month when when the Border would have
been shut down instead of letting say
10,000 12,000 people in so I guess you
could say it's an increment in the right
direction and at least it's a mandate as
opposed to the discretion but it is
nonetheless in the right direction
Senator Kramer if you did a town hall
this week in North Dakota and they got a
500 people to show up just on this issue
and you said okay a deal that I'm
considering supporting would actually
still allow President Biden to wave in
millions of migrants over the next year
but we're going to maybe get a few other
things on foreign workers and more
foreign worker visas and and thousands
and thousands of more what do you think
the reaction to the crowd in North
Dakota would be I have a hunch well if I
presented it like that they would
probably run me out
that's the way no no no no but but I
would do a more thorough job with it I'd
want to know who's who's where the
workers going to work Farm Workers North
dakot would say great we need more of
them energy workers wow we need more of
them oh in the medical field we'd like
some more of those but that's not what
but that's not what this bill is largely
about from everything that we've known
so far not seen text remember none of us
have seen text none of the critics have
seen text what we do know that's
negotiate because the negotiators well
sure but Senator Senator Senator I've
I've been here so much longer than you
and I don't mean to call rank cuz you're
a senator but this is the same old trick
they always pulled they pulled it with
Obamacare they pull it with these
Omnibus spending bills that horrify most
Americans when they see what's in them
and it's like okay let's hurry up and
negotiate and we've done doing it for
four months but now you have 72 hours to
read 700 Pages go that's no way to
legislate it's a complete and utter scam
and that's what's happening certainly is
not it it certainly is not except that
nobody's called for the vote Laur I
don't know how much time we're going to
have to to make the decision after we
actually get to see the text but the
things that we have that we do know that
all the negotiators agree to because
they say it out loud are there are some
real triggers uh there is expedited
removal at the border they are building
an infrastructure that requires people
to turn around the same day up to to a
certain amount raising the standard for
Asylum the cred credible fear standard
raising that higher doing away with the
stroke of of everybody being on parole
so there are some good things in the
right direction so just I want to be I
want to be clear I want to be clear to
the people of of North Dakota and the
people of the country because you're an
important senator in all of this and you
actually endorsed president Trump I know
in December and he's completely against
this he said let wait until I get in
there you don't need all this stuff to
do this right he's right about that but
but you're saying tonight that given
what's happened over the last 3 years
you actually have faith that pieces of
paper are going to make Alejandro
mayorcas who's about to be impeached by
the house or could be impeached by the
house actually enforce the these new
Provisions when he's not enforcing the
old ones I know if we do nothing he's
not going to be a better DHS secretary
he's not going to do you're giving Biden
cover you're you're giving Biden
political cover in an election year why
would you do that given what this man
has done to our
country well listen I endorsed Donald
Trump early this time and I endorsed him
really early the last time and the
reason I didn't endorse him earlier this
time was because my governor was running
having said all of that there's no
question Donald Trump will use these
tools to much greater effect than Joe
Biden does but I don't think we should
reserve the crisis for you know October
to give Joe Biden cover because anybody
that knows anything knows Joe Biden has
already lost this argument he's already
allowed 10 million people into the
interior of the country illegally so
it's not like he's going to one day be
known as the guy that took care of the
Border crisis right well senator this
does not end cat Catch and Release as as
anyone has described it thus far would
you agree with that well I I don't
entirely agree with it because if you
raise the standard and you do away with
the parole and you and you turn people
away at the border at a much greater
number I will say this to to your point
C that won't happen tomorrow they may
change the law if it's F if we get 5,000
a surge of 5,000 it automatically shuts
the Border down oh the Border be shut
down right now but if we have
infrastructure to do the Asylum um
reviews at the border for 5,000 then you
eliminate Catch and Release
clearly all right well we'll be watching
this closely and we really appreciate
your coming on tonight thank you so much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere
else